daniel hat das lavabo
repariert
fünf minuten später
tina ist
ausgerutscht
tina was ist passiert
ich bin im bad ausgerutscht
warum
weil der boden nass war
es hat begonnen
zu regnen
sein regenschirm ist kaputt gewesen
er ist nass geworden
er hat gefroren
er hat sich erkältet fred was ist
passiert
ich habe mich erkältet warum hast du
dich erkältet
weil es geregnet hat um dich nass
geworden bin
lisa ist gerannt
sie ist müde geworden
uns ist hingefallen
sie hat sich ihr bein
gebrochen
lisa was ist passiert ich habe mir mein
bein gebrochen
warum hast du dir dein bein gebrochen
weil ich im fitnesscenter vom laufband
gefallen bin
anton hat viel süßes gegessen aber er
hat die zähne nicht geputzt
danach hat der zahnschmerzen bekommen
die zahnärztin hatten einen zahn gezogen
anton was ist passiert die zahnärztin
hat mir einen zahn gezogen
warum
weil ich die zähne nicht geputzt habe